now President Biden is back to blaming
Trump and Maga Republicans for his
National Security and Border crises
blasting them for the faltering border
bill every day between now and November
the American people are going to know
that the only reason the border is not
secure is Donald Trump and his maggot
Republican friends it's time for
republicans in the Congress to show a
little courage to show a little spine to
make it clear to the American people
that you work for them not for anyone
else I know who I work for I work for
the American people later Peter Ducey
pressed the white house over the
president's Blame
Game you guys talk a lot including today
about how the Border wouldn't be such a
big deal if Congress would have just
passed their immigration bill on day one
who was in charge of Congress on day one
we have said is that Congress has to act
right Congress Democrats Republicans
have to act but in those 3 years it is
true that Republicans have gotten in the
way I mean they voted they've actually
voted years no responsib it has I'm not
saying that Democrats have not been in
control the first two years that's not
what I'm saying I'm saying House
Republicans have gotten in the way such
an agile verbal ballerina so even though
Democrats have been in control it's
still the gop's fault pointing the
finger at Trump and house Republicans
over the failure of the Senate border
bill seems odd when the Administration
has been claiming that the Border hasn't
been a crisis at all for the past few
years remember this it happens every
single solitary year we've dealt with
this before uh it is often seasonal uh
it is often cyclical the Border remains
closed we have seen extreme progress
over these last few months what
Americans should know is that the
president uh has done uh has done the
work to deal with what we're seeing at
the border since day
one there seems to be a lot of attempted
gaslighting going on Harris at the end
of the day while the administration is
changing their tune on whether or not it
needs addressing they're not changing
their tune on it being somehow trumps
and the gop's fault well it's a twofer
because it's an election year and by the
way brilliant on you agile verbal
ballerina which is so much upgraded from
word salad I mean that was amazing and
it's so true uh look it's an election
year and you've got to be able to do two
things you you've got to take down your
opponent and find a way to excuse while
you've been deficient in fixing one of
the worst situations that we've seen in
a really long time in this country so I
he's going to try to do that Democrats
are going to try to help him do that and
then they're going to shift and bring in
some shiny objects like Obama and
Clinton and hope that we don't all see
the Border but we can't stop seeing it
because we live in cities that are being
overrun resource Source wise and human
wise you know we're seeing the crimes
we're we're seeing you know this idea
that that our veterans don't get paid
first in the bills and and the budgets
cut so the reality is going to be really
hard he's going to need to do a 3fer
he's going to need to do the you know
hit us over the head with the magic wand
and make us forget reality thing too and
you contrast that all of that Kaye with
the leadership expressed and and really
um just embodied by Speaker Johnson last
hours we heard him simply on the Fly
talking to a gaggle of reporters now
rather than playing the blame game
gaslighting freaking out what he did was
standing in front of reporters and he
said in answer to the question what do
you say to Americans who are sort of
like what are you doing with your time
and are you getting anything done he
said we are governing he said sometimes
it's just messy but rest assured there
are steady Hands on the Wheel now that
is a capable leadership and body yeah
and houseal speaker Mike Johnson's one
of those steady hands do you remember I
got to interview him and he was very
calm am made the chaos of the
multi-speaker vote um because he
believes in someone much greater than
him guiding the way so I have great
faith in house Speaker Mike Johnson
someone I don't have faith in is the
president want to quote him yesterday
every day between now in November the
American people are going to know that
the only reason the border is not secure
is Donald Trump and his magga Republican
friends that's not parody that's not
Saturday Night Live that is something
our president said which No One Believes
In BC who do you trust to handle the
Border 57 to 22 Trump over Biden Biden
is the arsonist who is trying to blame
the firefighter no you're the arsonist
President Biden you lit 94 executive
actions on fire that destroyed the Trump
border policy and in turn lit the border
on fire you're the arsonist here ripping
away remain in Mexico ripping away title
42 ripping away the construction of the
border wall you're responsible it takes
such a level of self- delusion and
arrogance to say this is Trump and the
Maga Republicans who are stronger On the
Border than any movement or president in
the last probably three four decades
maybe maybe even longer but good try
that one try the self- delusion may work
in your mind not going to work for the
American people now Leslie to kayle's
point so anyone can say a lie but what
doesn't lie are the facts and as we have
the facts here to show you the number of
migrants being apprehended at our
Southern border has surged dramatically
since President Biden took office 2.4
million under Trump and nearly 8 million
migrant encounters so far under
President Biden so to kayle's point
doesn't it seem obvious that under one
president the fire was tamped down and
under another Flames are out of control
I don't think it's that black and white
I mean there are certain things I mean
postco you have a lot of Nations
throughout the world that have gotten
worse fortunately the United States is
not one of them we keep getting better
we got hit but we came back strong and
we'll be stronger that's not the case so
you have more people fleeing yes title
42 there is something to that but there
is also that was also a measure for a
Time Co is over you can't have remain in
mexic remain in I remain in Mexico
Mexico doesn't want remain in Mexico
anymore so Mexico is saying NAA no MOS
so threat them with TR
it what we can what we can do and what
was not ble to be done during the Bush
Administration the Obama Administration
even the Trump Administration the bid
every Administration is Congress has to
pass a
multifaceted immigration
compr that's going to happen that's why
they're rating we talk about when we
talk about the rep what the Republicans
are doing and I agree with Harris that
it is an election year and immigration
if I was a republican that would be what
I was talking about day night I ask a
simple question is this an emergency
what's happening at the border yes but
this this so in an Emergen what do you
do you send FEMA and everything you have
and you
do medical emergency I want to weigh in
on that title 42 according to Robert
Redfield talked to me directly about
this was not just intended for covid he
had it in mind because of flu and
there's all kinds of public health
problems leaking across the border right
now title 42 remain in Mexico as you say
building the wall but here's the here's
the bigger issue did you look at this
bill this bill is a road to Asylum
actually it's appointing more Asylum
officers to the Border granted the goal
is to preserve humanitarianism but in
the end it's just putting a lot more
resources a lot more money on a road to
Asylum with remain in Mexico you have to
prove you're supposed to be here all we
need to do doctor all we need to do is
have Asylum not here in the United
States Congress can pass legislation
changing our Antiquated as legislation
did Trump sign into law legislation no
he didn't need it he used executive
action could do the point is you really
trust the the people granted the courts
are overwhelmed with this issue but and
this legislation would appoint more
judges this legislation would appoint
more border border patroling but the
border patrol people cannot cannot be
there to decide who deserves Asylum and
who should remain in another country
that's not their role and they're not
trained for that and the bill allows for
that and I think the legislation
operates at a 30,000 foot you know
Stratosphere layer well underneath that
all of the protections that were wiped
away the 94 executive actions thew that
aren't being enforced it's the trauma
that's occurring the hemorrhaging that's
occurring that no amount of legislation
will um address until everything in
between is addressed in that acute
formation hey everyone I'm Emily compano
catch me and my co-host Harris vulner
and Kaye mcaneny on outnumbered every
weekday at 12: p.m. Eastern or sets your
DVR also don't forget to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page for daily
highlights